on est chez nous max nouveau départ
c'est sa neuvième nouveau départ les
déménagements
je te promets
nous avons un nouvel élève monsieur mac
graff max mcgrath le fils de jean mas
graff alors pourquoi tout le monde sait
plus de trucs sur mon père que moi dans
ce trouble tu connaissais mon père il
faut que je sache
dans son travail ton père travaillait
sur la possibilité de stocker plus
d'énergie plus qu'aucun être humain ne
peut l'imaginer il était sur le point de
faire une découverte qu'est ce qui
m'arrive
max non t'approche pas toi je m'appelle
sting toi tu sais parler à ma mère va
monter est ce que ma mère est dangereux
droit non non c'est pas ça ou par fraude
il faut nettoyer il faut nettoyer sa vie
de mon cher c'est toi qui m'a fait ça
non c'est ton père qui t'a donné ses
pouvoirs je suis là pour te montrer
comment les utiliser allez on commence
max qui peuvent utiliser ton énergie de
flamme manière
je peux courir plus vite
[Musique]
être plus fort
et a pas encore vu le fin du fin c'est
quoi ton
alors ça c'est énorme de rien
mas sofia ça va tout oui j'ai juste peur
d'être en retard pour moi ça commence à
être ennuyeux mon cours de zumba la
créature féminine semble faire augmenter
ton pot tu devrai éviter le contact toi
peut-être que tu devrais la firme jiwa
elle te met en colère les ultras bing ce
sont là pour détruire la terre
que ton énergie qui pourra les en
empêcher on est là sonorama j'arrive pas
à croire que je vais faire ça
doit apprendre à contrôler ses pouvoirs
car maintenant à gauche non on va à
droite accord
en course lui même en public
ton père voulait sauver le monde
[Musique]
donc tour maintenant max
si naïve et l'émotion
tu vas bien oui
c'était pas pire que d'habitude